caminaron dos días para liberarse de
ocho años de secuestro a guayana to us
en parte de las niñas de chivos
estudiantes secuestradas en 2014 por
boko haram en el norte de nigeria el
viernes el ejército les presento a la
prensa junto a ruth de 24 años que
encontraron hace unos días con su hijo
de dos años tres de las niñas de chivo
que están aquí con ustedes
bruce agua nunca y anna tumulto musa
desde 2014 de las 276 niñas de chivos
algunas lograron escapar otras han sido
intercambiadas por comandantes del grupo
yihadista en negociaciones con las
autoridades pero más de 100 siguen
desaparecidas actualmente en abril a
cumplir ocho años desde el secuestro
amnistía internacional acusó a las
autoridades nigerianas de incumplir su
deber de proteger a los niños ya que
según la ong más de 1500 estudiantes han
sido secuestrados en nigeria desde el
drama de chivo que las autoridades se
han mostrado muy reacias tanto a
investigar estos ataques como exigir
responsabilidades a los autores de estos
crímenes atroces cada nuevo ataque va
acompañado de nuevos secuestros que
privan a los jóvenes de su derecho a la
libertad y dejan a las familias de las
víctimas sin esperanza de acceder a la
justicia la verdad o la reparación
[Música]
en el noreste de nigeria la insurgencia
está lleva 13 años un conflicto interno
que mató a 40.000 personas y desplazó a
más de 2 millones